>> Greg: IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK THAT WORK.
NO ONE CAN OVER SHARE AT THE
PRINCE WITH RED HAIR.
HE EMBARRASSED HIS FAMILY FOR
FUN, NOW HIS TOWELS IS NUMBER
ONE PRINCE HARRY'S BOOK HAS NOW
BECOME THE FASTEST SELLING
NONFICTION BOOK IN THE HISTORY
OF THE U.K. PLANE FORMED A
THOUSAND COPIES ON TUESDAY SHE
ONLY BOOKED EVER SO MORE COPIES
IN ITS FIRST DAY THEN
HARRY POTTER WHICH ALSO WAS A
WORK OF FICTION.
[APPLAUSE]
ANYWAY.
THE BOOK ALSO REVEALS A WHOLE
BUNCH OF WEIRD, TEXT MESSAGE
FIGHT BETWEEN MEGAN AND KATE HAS
A HUSBAND GET THAT AND WHAT IS
EVEN CARE ALSO PRINCE CHARLES
WHO SAID YOU HAD STANDS IN HIS
UNDERWEAR EVERY DAY TO ALLEVIATE
INJURIES FROM POLO NOT POLIO.
POLO.
STUPID.
AND THEN THERE WAS THAT TIME
THAT HE SUFFERED FROSTBITE ON
HIS FROM A TRIP TO THE
NORTH POLE SURE HE DIDN'T GET
FROM MEGAN?
YEAH IT'S CONTAGIOUS FROSTBITE.
I THINK I KNOW I'M NOT A DOCTOR.
IT'S TITLED SPARE WHICH COMES
FROM HIS CLAIM THAT HE WAS BREAD
ONLY TO OFFER SPEAR ORGANS TO
PRINCE WILLIAMS.
I KNOW ALTHOUGH THE BEST OUT OF
LUCK GENERATING HER PLACE.
BUT AS AN EXCLUSIVE CLAIM THAT
HE WAS BORN TO PROVIDE SPARE
PARTS I PREFERRED WAY BACK WHEN
THEY CREATED HEIRS THE
OLD-FASHIONED WAY AND BY BANGING
THEIR COUSINS.
KAT YOU ARE A HUGE FAN OF
ROYALTY BUT FOLLOWING WHAT IS
HARRY'S LAST NAME?
>> Kat: I HAVE NO IDEA.
SOON I KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
THIS GUY BUT I DON'T KNOW HIS
LAST NAME.
THAT'S BECAUSE MEN LOVE TO TALK
THEIR [BLEEP].
>> Greg: EVEN BAD STORIES.
>> Kat: ANY TIME THEY CAN FIT
THAT IN THERE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: WE WERE ALL THINKING
AND A YOU SAID IT.
>> Kat: LIKE I SAID.
C1 WHAT HUSBAND BUT ACTUAL TEXT
BETWEEN THE TWO SISTERS IN THE
BOOK?
IN A PERSON DOES THAT?
>> Kat: EVERYONE IS TO BE
REALLY CAREFUL AND NOT HANG OUT
WITH THEM EVER.
YEAH, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THIS
WAS A TELL ALL.
WHICH MEANS THAT THEY TOLD THAT
ALL AND NOW THEY NEEDED TELL
MORE.
THEY ARE GOING TO NEED TO FIND
OTHER PEOPLE TO GET DIRT FROM
AND THEN THAT'LL BE IN THE NEXT
BOOK SO IT SEEMS LIKE THE FIGHT
YOU OVER BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
COME ALL THIS ONE SENTENCE WAS A
CAME OVER AND DID THIS AND
THAT'LL BE THE NEXT BOOK.
STAY BETTER NOT HAVE A SINGLE
FRIEND EVER AGAIN IF YOU KNOW
IT'S GOOD FOR YOU.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU CAN'T TRUST
THEM TO THINK THAT HE REALLY
BELIEVES THAT HE WAS BREAD FOR
SPREAD PARTS?
>> Bill: HE WAS CAN PROVIDE
ORGAN FOR WILLIAM?
HAVE YOU SEEN SOME OF HIS PARTY
PICKS OF HARRY BACK IN THE DAY
CHRIS MARK IS IN WHICH I PUT THE
WILLIAM?
[LAUGHS]
I'M DUE A DOUBLE TAKE OF EXCESS
PRIVACY LIKE PUBLISHING A
MEMOIR.
OF EXCESS PRIVACY LIKE LET ME
TELL YOU ABOUT THIS.
STEVIE WONDER ALL ABOUT MAKING
THE MONEY IT WAS NEVER ABOUT
PRIVACY IT'S ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTS SHOULD DO A LITTLE
YEAH HA >> LISTEN I WATCHED A
SIX PART DOCUMENT ON NETFLIX SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
>> Tyrus: SHAME ON YOU, SHAME
ON YOU.
>> Bill: IT'S ENTIRELY
SELF-INDULGENT.
BUT NETFLIX HAS A NEW FEATURE
YOU CAN WATCH MOVIES FASTER
NEVER DO BEFORE YOU GET TO BE
YOU THAT CIRCLE ME TELL YOU.
[LAUGHS]
>> Tyrus: SOMETIMES WHEN YOU
WORK WITH A LOT OF WHITE PEOPLE
SOMETIMES YOU FORGET THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SENSE THAT WE
HAVE LIKE I KNOW OF A BUILDING'S
ABOUT GO DOWN I LEAVE I DON'T GO
TO CHECK TO WISH LIKE ALES
INVESTIGATE YET Y'ALL GO RIGHT
AHEAD.
I LEAVE.
HOW CAN YOU NOT TELL THAT HE DID
NOT WRITE THIS BOOK, SHE WROTE
THIS BOOK.
WHAT MAN HAS SAVED TEXT MESSAGES
FROM HIS GIRL?
NO.
ALL HE DID SEE THAT FACE?
THAT WAS HIS FACE DURING THE
ENTIRE TIME.
WHAT SHE TOLD EVERY DIRTY SECRET
SHE COULD.
YOUR DADDY'S TO DO HANDSTANDS
AND IS UNAWARE?
IT'S IN THE BOOK.
RIM OF THE HE TOLD ME THEY WANT
THAT BIG IS BECAUSE IT FROSTBITE
A TORCH IN CONFIDENCE.
YOUR BROTHER WAS USING HER FOR
SPARE PARTS AND NO ONE HAD THE
BILLION ROOM TO SAY THAT AS AN
ICY WERE QUITE LIKE THAT.
AT ALL.
I GIVE A SHOT THAN I CAN
MANEUVER TO THE SIDE CHRIS MARK
WHEN THEY GO BEEN INSIDE A GLASS
CLUED YOUR ENTIRE LIFE.
IN CASE OF INJURY BREAK GLASS
USE ARM.
SHE WROTE IT SHE IS GONNA KEEP
ON IT IN ABOUT TWO AND HALF
YEARS FOR A BROKEN, BROKE GUY;
DAD HEY, IS OKAY?
DO NOT READ THIS BOOK IT'S HER
BOOK WITH HIS FACE ON IT.
>> Greg: I NEVER EVEN CONSIDER
IT BUT THE TEXT AT ALL MAKES
SENSE HAVE YOU BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS AS CLOSELY AS I HAVE
QUESTION RICKY SAID BEFORE THE
SEVEN I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
ROYALTY.
>> Rob: I'VE BEEN CELEBRATING
THIS FOR 3-4 MINUTES NOW.
I'VE COME TO THIS CONCLUSION
PRINCE HARRY AMAZING [BLEEP]
CHANGE HISTORY.
[APPLAUSE]
THIS EROTIC PLEASURE I SHALL NO
LONGER DENY MYSE